rebbetzin Tasha so you become a fighter
HTC Desire even in ateres enjoy a day
after she also still up to toe wats
adult opossum ninja of the general term
rent a yacht a yacht eros occur after
controller or not talking originality of
there and there are my makeup ninja me
hace de llamada irrational enchiladas
subarashii we can all say God
so snap ano ba gonna skin again tu mano
a snack or submit there was a Moche up
today at greater their gypsy man in
general you both yeah summarize
for me good at back through google
automakers solo kamil çetin is there a
ninja gaiden tu sais que Cara naka de
Mayo salad destination ready to start
our CTO instict an article today has
been so the snake
Ninjago Bopara I
[ __ ] in the morning angel
ninja normal
door challenging a cowboy don't owe
anybody a food
so on all set then
so we are
the mother
I think it's interesting because
culturally obviously you come at things
from your own standpoint and it's
interesting when you're challenged by
other people to say like why do you do
it that way I think hopefully people
will see there's a bit of a fusion going
on here and that we're bringing new
ideas to the japanese closing games and
they're bringing new ideas of what we
were traditionally did I'm do but that's
gotta might see me ninja you got away
after you mr. Pedro siktir whatever no
no harm aesthetics ditch their other or
the other state with also sweet harder
foreign language capacity of magnitude
or actually the person or more sweet let
it go to another game enough to Moscow
there
not all
normal i end up with an adapter move
that I don't doubt they buy a gun cool
we got just go to action given to your
court honestly middle yaiba is a
collaboration between three distinct
teams that have all come together with a
sort of a different background and its
really interesting collaboration having
the opportunity to work with with mr.
and a few nay with all the experience
that he's brought to the table and his
really drive and passion for innovation
trying to do something new in this space
as well as a lot of the experience
that's come from all the combat design
that team ninjas done in the past with
the ninja gaiden games and then sparks
bringing a lot of the sort of action and
western side of the the design
philosophy to the table as well and so
it really makes for a very well-rounded
experience and also we're all working
together so we're not trying to sort of
divide ourselves as far as our
backgrounds and go and things like that
you